So a different kind of partitioning
strategy is known as multi-level graph
coarsening.
It's a form of divide and conquer.
Let's start with
a conceptual illustration.
You start with an imput graph,
pretend this is an input graph.
You would then replace it
with a smaller version.
In the graph sense, the coarse graph
would have fewer nodes and edges, but
would somehow look like
the original graph.
We might repeat this a few times until
you get a version of the graph that is
small enough to partition quickly.
You then partition the smallest graph.
If you've done a good job preserving the
relationship between the coarsest graph
and its parent graph,
then a split in the course graph will
correspond to a roughly equivalent
split in the fine graph.
And you'd repeat this reverse step until
you have a partition of the original.
So that's the concept, but
how do you actually coarsen a graph?
Most schemes have the following flavor.
First, identify at least one subset of
the vertices to collapse or to merge.
For instance,
here's a subset of five vertices.
I'm going to replace this subset
with a single super vertex.
Now remember that one of your
partitioning goals is to obtain balanced
partitions.
So it's probably a good
idea to track the fact
that there were five vertices
here that became one vertex.
An easy way to do that is to assign
a weight of 5 to the super vertex.
You'll also want to
track edge weights so
that later on we can
cut edges accurately.
Let's see how that might work.
Consider two vertices
in a weighted graph.
Remember, even if the original graph
is unweighted, we repeatedly coarsen by
aggregating nodes and edges and
so will accumulate weights.
In this example, wi is a function that
maps every vertex to some weight.
Similarly, the function xi
will map edges to weights.
Now, let's suppose that we join just
these two vertices into a super-vertex.
Let's call this new vertex s.
Its weight is the sum of
the weights of u and v.
Now, what about the edge weights?
The main case to think
about is the following.
Suppose there's a vertex t that's
connected to both u and v.
Then these two edges will
become a single super-edge
in the coarsened graph.
So what is its weight?
A natural idea is simply to sum
the weights of the original edges.
So the weight of the new edge
is just the weight of the two
old edges that got merged.
The reason we do this is so
that if we partition or cut this edge in
the coarsened graph, we'll know that it
maps to two edges in the original graph.
Now before you move on,
it's a good idea to check that
this procedure makes sense to you.
Okay, let's go back to
the original sample graph and
see what would happen by
applying these rules.
Consider this first merge group again.
There are 5 vertices,
which become 1 super-vertex.
There are also several cases in
which multiple edges should merge.
Here is the result.
Now, let's suppose someone gives
us a sequence of merge groups, and
let's coarsen the graph accordingly.
[SOUND] Coarsen, coarsen.
[SOUND] So this is the final result.
That's the basic process
of coarsening a graph.
This final result kind of
looks like something.
Oink, do you know about
Atlanta's PINK PIG ride?